okay it's Alex and today I'm gonna be
watching my first solo behind tasty
episode making chocolate croissants
so I say first solo episode because the
first behind tasty episode was actually
rainbow crib cake that I did with Alexis
this videos a couple of years old though
I haven't really watched it since it was
also very traumatic experience though
I've stayed away from watching it for
good reason also can I just know it is
very intimidating to have to be on
camera in front of a lot of people like
that and again this was like one of my
first so this was I think my first solo
on camera video ever misspoke once hi
guys I'm Alex I'm it tasty hi guys I'm
out okay hi guys I'm Alex I'm a TV
producer and today I'm going to make to
say I have learned that I really put my
foot in my mouth a lot through this
series as long as people are laughing I
think I've done my job we haven't even
gotten to the croissants yet you see
this intro is gonna be harder than the
damn chocolate croissants
Oh me I'm good times good time
there hi guys I'm Alex I'm a TV producer
and today I'm going to be making
chocolate croissants I've never made
chocolate croissants before no this is
going to be great
I hear the hardest part about making
croissants is that you have to keep the
dough completely cold the whole time I
just also want to note this is one of
the hardest recipes you can make on your
own it was funny when we started this
series especially the episodes that I
was doing we specifically chose recipes
that were super hard to make on your own
so that we could build out more of a
journey of a video where you saw my
childhood there were some commenters
that were like how did this girl get a
job like she can't even do her job they
were really fun shoots and I look back
at these videos at least I'm gonna look
back at this video and remember my
triumphs in the end so so here comes a
trick you're gonna grate the butter
right into the dough I've had this not a
few minutes and I already feel it's
getting a little bit this is the hard
part
especially when you're doing trial and
error with recipes there's so many
different variations of recipes online
or in books and also for the purpose of
this video because it was our first one
and we're still trying to figure out the
flow of behind tasty they didn't want me
to do like any research prior or like
any of the preparation because they
wanted to capture it all on camera so
this shoot specifically ended up being
like the longest one because I didn't do
any of that prior research and I went in
pretty much blind for this video I had
to try out a few different variations
because some of those recipes that I
found online did not work let me tell ya
and then I'm just gonna kind of oh yeah
again I mean there's so many different
aspects that go into making croissants
temperature is a huge one I learned and
I got to keep everything really really
cold that's the reason I was actually
using this marble slab here because that
was like the coldest surface that we had
to be able to keep the dough chilled for
as long as possible because if the
butter melts you're not gonna get the
layers Baker please actually do I never
claimed to be a good Baker I actually
I'm Way better at cooking than baking
this is good though if you make your own
croissants then you can eat them too
because you'll have worked out yeah it
was definitely don't work out cracking a
little bit I don't know if that's we're
going with it so now I gotta I gotta
work fast actually okay
how many dough's is down I think I was
supposed to flour the surface actually
so let's rewind and I'm also gonna flour
the rolling pin okay that's hard very
hard to I do remember this from the
dough also like in between putting the
dough in the fridge we were like
bringing ice packs to put on the marble
slab so be cool they're like running
around trying to control all the
different things but
[Music]
literally been sorry my wife let's just
piece it all back together pretend
nothing happened
I didn't it's looking better I mean I'm
definitely getting them but I also know
what's gonna happen people kept telling
me this all move to two weeks like oh
I'm never gonna make croissants again
that was like this really doesn't help
me because I've already committed if you
notice I'm not wearing black today I'm
trying to avoid the finger prints I'm
anticipating there's gonna be hard again
that's what's also tricky with this
recipe is that with any croissants it
takes a few days the process takes a few
days
so messing up the first day threw us off
schedule for the rest of the days of the
shoot he actually had a deadline but we
far missed it it was my bad sorry Nathan
it's easier oh this is awkward looks
like a dress or something
an hourglass not the figure you would
have so laughing but if I were never
inside I would like I don't actually
think I can do I was hopeful about
baking there's at 450 the roll up
tonight but okay it was more like a
bread dough
well I was trying to make a one day
that's just my style you know I like to
cut corners just cut to the point in
life I guess that's a good lesson
something that's supposed to be a three
day process and hopefully the last day
[Music]
this still looked really nice though I
was really hopeful for this good it's
always hot okay I actually do have a
story to tell you can even see it in my
eyes that I look a little bit dead
inside there's a few steps that go into
making croissants obviously but for the
purpose of the length of the video we
cut some stuff out also this was a very
traumatic experience so we cut it out
because you didn't want to see it anyway
so I put them in this little tiny oven
it's like half oven because no one ever
uses it and I put them in there just to
be safe and then it's supposed to proof
for like I think it was like an hour or
like something like that I don't know
how long again it's like kind of blacked
out and I've every but like I think it's
like 10 or 15 minutes 20 minutes even I
decide to go look at them just to see
how my babies are doing what they're you
know talking about and I go over to the
oven and my world starts to crash in on
me because someone had turned the oven
on if I was already on the verge of a
mental breakdown like this was it cuz it
was at that point I was like do I keep
baking them or
like take him out like they're delicate
so it's like I don't want them to fall
or you know it was just like what do I
do and they were already starting to
brown on top
luckily Riya the dessert snob helped me
out she gave me like advice on what to
do to just take them out to leave them
to prove for the final minutes and then
to just bake them off and they ended up
working
oh my god but they didn't look good okay
and this part so I think after all of
that the whole two weeks or whatever how
long it was and then that day where it
was just like traumatic it was very
delirious and in my mind I just thought
it would be so funny if we did this like
slow-motion shot where I'm in glasses
like looking cool bringing my croissants
out to the kitchen in my mind it looked
a lot cooler than it actually was it was
so funny and we had to do this like 50
times because I kept laughing
it was like a parade in my mind but I
feel like people didn't get it like
why'd she put on sunglasses and then I
tripped you can see I'm like delirious
[Music]
support your local Baker I love that
line I've learned anything that's
important local Baker myself there is
nothing like a homemade croissants no
taste of it all right wow that was a
journey I mean it's fun actually to look
back I'm glad at least that if I had to
go through that long of an experience
that at least I get a funny video that I
get to remember and look back on and I
haven't seen it in a while so it's funny
to remember the good old days support
your local Baker
[Music]